so did you know february 4th did you
hear about this document that russia and
china put out together a statement so
they issued a statement february 4th
together
that is a couple of pages long and it if
you read that statement that happened
before russia even invaded ukraine they
pretty much declare i mean it's the most
ominous statement because they
essentially come out declaring we're no
longer going to have a unipolar world it
is now multi-polar and these are that
yeah these this is how this is you know
this
basically pointing the finger at the
west almost blatantly that they don't i
don't know if they actually name the
united states in the document but they
essentially
they strongly allude saying
we're the reason why there isn't world
peace that it's our fault and that the
time the things have changed this is it
this is the document the china aerospace
studies institute in their own words
joint statement of the russian
federation the people's republic of
china on the international relations
entering a new era of the of the global
sustainable development
well there you go
it's decently long i'm not gonna read
the whole thing but no but there's parts
of it um that really
they really call out the american
hegemony and when you look at this and
you think okay the purpose of war is to
stop the influence or to or to um weaken
your enemy to some degree so war doesn't
have to be with guns and i think there's
been a concerted effort when you look at
this and then you look at the steps that
russia has taken and then you see the
steps that china has taken in response
to it and you realize that we might have
been at war china might have been at war
with us china and russia for a long time
right because really it's just about you
have an enemy you don't like the enemy
you want to harm the enemy in some way
it doesn't have to and they know they
couldn't beat us militarily nor did they
even want to
so they i think went after us
economically potentially yeah you want
con conquest or genocide i think are the
two main goals of war yeah it's usually
to empower yourself through the
destruction of the other um and that
doesn't have to be done with guns that
can be done psychologically like you see
children questioning their gender that's
basically
it's not genocide but if people stop
having babies that's the end of the
human rights it's control of a
population
so
if you could take over a country without
firing a shot would you do it of course
nobody wants to waste resources right so
if you've got if you've got a country
that's got a bunch of nuclear reactors
do you want to blow them up or do you
want to use them you want to use them
anybody who's played the game
civilization knows this if you can take
over a city with minimal you know
bombings you get more from that city you
blow them up the population shrinks and
you get a crappier city just basic math
so they've been planning this for a long
time because they were trading in
dollars in 2014 i think the percentage
of dollars being traded between china
and russia was like 97
and now it's down to 30 something
percent that they use so they've been
doing that they've been making these
moves for a long time they have been
building up their own economies
strengthening their own ties with one
another they used to be enemies now
they're like best buddies um and they've
been making all of these really really
strategic moves making friends around
the world rather than enemies
and now suddenly it's just really
strange to me
that russia decides to invade ukraine
when was it the 21st of february so they
issued this statement on the 4th russia
does a giant deal for a natural gas
pipeline
from ukraine to i mean from russia to
china giant pipeline and then suddenly
he goes in and invades ukraine like as
you know and i know a lot of it of
course they've been saying it's about
nato expansion but
why now were they gonna do a vote next
week to put ukraine into nato like
what's so different this week from last
week you see the video of the russian
politician in december saying february
22nd 2022 i wish this year would have
been peaceful but it's not gonna be mark
my words in december he said that and uh
that video's not getting a lot of play
but a lot of like i'm so a ukrainian
friend said that to me they were like
watch this video and then i was just
like whoa
so they knew
they knew and uh truth be told i didn't
believe the us when they were putting
out these statements they were like
russia's going to do it and i was like
well look it's the democrat who cried
russia right you know joe biden or jen
sackey or these democrats are like you
know nancy pelosi comes out and she's
like the russians are going to invade
and i'm like shut your mouth you liar i
will not believe a word that comes out
of these people's mouths and to our own
detriment what do you do
well they were right this one time
i mean it's like i said on yesterday's
show the moral of the story and the boy
who cried wolf was not oh those shameful
stupid villagers for not believing the
one time he turned out to be right the
moral of the story is it's his fault
because he lied consistently and lost
all credibility we should make uh uh we
should make
that kid's book the democratic cried
russian but the moral of the story is
you should always believe the democrats
no matter what when they're completely
wrong yeah so like it's the basic story
the bow cried wolf in the end it's just
like if only they had just continued to
believe the little boy who lied all the
time they would have been better off
shows you to always obey the authority
that's true the authority is never wrong
correct
yeah so what else is going on though i
mean we've been seeing china and russia
dumping us dollars for a long time now
and i remember conversations back in
like the late 2000s where they were like
china and russia are getting prepared
for a non-petro dollar non-us reserve
currency world yeah it's going to like
the how do you say it the ewon you won
they saw the petro e1 is what they're
moving towards it sounds is that what i
should be buying right now
well maybe and isn't it so sad that the
elites in our country are so
unbelievably irresponsible and corrupt
that we don't even want to hold on to
our own currency because we all
basically believe it's going to collapse
and we're actively watching it lose
a large portion of its value yeah yeah
only eight percent that's what we're
being told i think it was march 2020
when they first did that print was it
1.2 trillion maybe it was april 2020
that was when i gave up on the us dollar
i was like wow okay i've known the
federal reserve's busted the economy and
the fiats nuts and that american
military-industrial complex is over
overreach but it never really struck me
until march 2020 like wow they're just
gonna keep printing money it was um what
i understand it was that they were
giving
450 billion to the federal reserve to
leverage out in 4.5 trillion in loans
just completely flooding the market
the uh zubi tweeted this that the money
supply was 4 trillion in early 2020 and
now it's 20 trillion or something like
that or 23 trillion a lot of it's
because the savings accounts got
added to the money supply absolutely so
that's like half at least half i would
think of that no it's like it's like uh
it's more than half that number wow okay
okay
but they did it to mask the amount of
printing because if you look at the
number the money supply is going along
and all of a sudden they add the the
savings in and then the money supplies
increasing at a new rate before when
they added it's like right when they
added the supply you see it china and
russia saw what happened in 2008 and
they were like you better start
preparing because this is the end when
you look at the money supply the real
surge in money printing happened right
after that to right after 2008 after the
market crashed and then with the
epidemic it skyrockets yeah so i think
russia and china india brazil probably a
bunch of countries and i'm sure the u.s
even the united states yeah yeah no well
we i mean what happens is all the time
they argue that we have to use
quantitative easing in order to
stimulate the economy but then we get
completely addicted because as soon as
you try quantitative tightening the
stock market goes crazy and we can't
have that happen so they just have to
continually inflate the currency to
prevent a crash
i possobic is a brilliant man jack
posobi and he constantly is like you do
not want the us dollar to not be the
world reserve currency i'm like i know i
don't but i also don't want to be living
off fiat for my grandchildren to suffer
under the slave boot of authoritarian
autocracy
you know and and have their lot have
their their their lives valued by some
corporate credit i don't know what to do
i don't want to destroy the system but
the system is an aberration and needs to
be rectified i think the best we can
hope for is the multi-polar world where
it's more of a east-west and so we're
not dominating the world with one
currency but instead there's one
currency that's often traded
in parts of the world and another that
is traded in the other part of the world
and you know as the world's population
has increased that's fine i mean when
you look at the population 70 years ago
compared to today i think it's doubled
on the globe so even if the dollar is
only dominant with half the world it's
still the same number of people as it
was
70 years ago but but have you considered
that um you know the average person i
should say all people actually are
are stupid and that we should control
them with a small council of elites who
who have inherited their power and then
reset the whole system and then take
everything these people own away from
them and then once we do they'll be
happy
schwab is that you
know
like like some kind of economic forum
for the world
yeah like a world
economic forum of some sort of some kind
well when we were hanging out with ryan
and danny the other day we played that
video of the guy filling up the back of
his pickup truck that's what i'm
thinking about and i'm like now now you
understand bill gates but klaus schwab's
probably better klaus is like sitting
there and like he's sitting in his
lounge chair with his belly hanging out
he's like clicking youtube videos and
then he watches a guy pouring gas in the
back of a pickup truck and he's like i
must do something about this
kim do you when you think about like the
just the sheer stupidity of some humans
to destroy themselves and everyone
around them like what do you like the
plebeians and the roman times they were
like there's the elite central few that
runs society and everyone else is a
plebeian because they're too stupid to
understand at which end of the fork to
hold like how do you do you see do you
think that that's real that there's like
a small group of really hyper
intelligent humans and everyone else is
like a dumb like a follower and that we
need to live like that we need to
structure society around that obviously
yes
how do you see it
because i'm having a hard time not
seeing it like that
i think i think ian makes a good point
because i'm sure many in the audience
think that about you no but i'm not
going to be funny sure a lot of people
there's
in this situation you're the leader i'm
the follower it's very specific what i
mean is there are a lot of people who
are like i think ian has bad ideas you
know what i mean
and so therefore we need to control you
yeah right right yeah like there are
people there the idea that there are
people you cannot let run society
because they'll fill the back of their
truck up with gasoline right i will say
this there is a there is a brilliant
fulton sheen quote we cannot allow
society to be led by people who never
learned to obey it in other words we are
run by people who never learned to
follow the rules and always saw
themselves as above the law and so what
happens when they take control they're
completely lawless and that's tyranny
but everybody feels that way about
everybody so that's the problems then
who do you decide you know exactly when
you look at it just even in our
government now you've got democrats
thinking that and then you have
republicans thinking that so which one
are you going to choose yeah
unfortunately i don't think i do decide
at this point i've becoming i've become
a jaded cynic i'm i'm just all about i'm
going to go live in the woods i'm going
to get a bunch of chickens you already
did that i know i i hear what you're
saying i live by my you know i
my word is your code yeah my code i hear
what you're saying about the fact that
there are a lot of different
perspectives on this but we also have to
be very careful not to fall into the
trap of relativism and still be willing
to acknowledge that there is truth hood
and falsehood and the best we can do is
try to pursue that which is good and
noble and pure and true as best as we
possibly can even if there's some
potential for us to get it wrong at
least we will have tried
i get i really don't like wealth that
wealth goes from parent to kid on death
that makes me so who should it go to
instead just disperse into nothingness
or something i don't know then why would
people want to earn wealth for their
children well you earn it for yourself
and then your children earn it for
themselves no am i on right now here i
am i'm listening to a commie and
somebody
who's like pushing for vaccine mandates
right what i'm pushing for vaccine
mandates i'm basically the
because when exact
say my morality is for the good of the
the greater good yes then that is
basically what people that push for
vaccine mandates say they say my
morality is for the greater good so but
do you believe that some moral claims
can be true and others can be false the
problem is not saying that there is good
and truth in the world and that we
should try to promote what is true the
issue is people trying to promote
falsehood as if it's true
i want to
oh i want to go deep on this well i want
to ask you a question because
everybody's posting one's in chat right
now after what he said oh book
i get your point yeah okay so uh imagine
this scenario you have a 40 year old man
he's got three kids
and they're
middle teenagers and he's a billionaire
and uh they have a big house
they have a very very large house and
they'll live in it and then uh one day
the guy is walking downstairs and he
sees his kids making breakfast and he
goes hello there's whoa and slips and
then falls on his neck and snap his neck
cracks
should the government come and burn the
house down and kick the kids out and put
them in an orphanage no so how do you
what do those kids do right
maybe there's like a
house an amount does okay so the
government comes in takes the house
kicks the kids out and gives them each
100 grand so like a giant tax i don't
know ninety percent tax why do those
kids have a hundred grand to begin with
well because well what do you like so
this is the issue this is this is why we
tr if somebody is working because they
want to provide for their kids
the problem is wealth doesn't mean rich
wealth is just the the reason the the
money and resources you have so there
could be a guy who's worth a hundred
thousand dollars
his total net worth this means he's got
12 000 in savings he's got a mortgage on
his house and you know liabilities plus
assets and equals about 100 grand and he
lives in the suburbs and his kids go to
school his kid's 16 17 years old and
then he dies and the mom dies or
whatever they both had a car accident
you got to transfer the parent's head to
the kids otherwise the kids are just
homeless so that's the way it works so
it's also interesting because ian there
have been some analyses which have
suggested that inheritance taxes make
income inequality worse because when you
look at middle class people generally
their best way of generating
intergenerational wealth is through
homeownership property ownership it's
basically what they can pass on to their
children and so we've also seen it
disproportionately harming farmers
because their wealth is stored up in
their land and the crops that they grow
and i just find it interesting how these
left-wing economic policies almost
always end up going after the people who
make our food it's not necessarily
intentional but it almost always ends up
uh
resulting in food becoming more
difficult to produce or more expensive
the owners of blackrock when they die
blackrock goes to their kids like why
well their shares yeah that's publicly
traded
it could be that i'm just talking about
something that's way too ahead of its
time because we're on the money system
as long as we're using money as our
currency we're there's going to be this
is worrying using currency you mean no
the currency has evolved over time it
used to be shells we would trade little
gems and shells and then we created
money as a currency type now we have
electricity as a currency type but like
it works the idea that money is the
final form of currency got us into this
position in the first place gotta stop
you there because you're just very money
is a form of currency man they're not
the same thing uh
okay you need a i think they're more
equitable
like electricity would make a lot you
know what do you know what like currency
is can you define it the definition i
could look it up really quick right a
trade medium
so that somebody who makes bread can
trade something that holds value as an
intermediary shells are money gems are
money no no they're currency money is a
type of currency as a trade medium what
what's like lightweight cash yeah well
whether you do it in a dollar bill or
you do it in a seashell it's the same
thing or electricity
but we don't we don't trade no
electricity is different that would be
like i trade you bread for the
electricity so that's the trading of
goods and what currency does is it
allows for me to trade
i am i don't want your electricity i
don't think electricity is what's going
on
i think it's cut to the point where if
we don't have it we're screwed well ian
can i ask you
how would you correct for the double
coincidence of wants that she was just
explaining the problem with sometimes
one person who's generating wealth
doesn't necessarily have something that
they can trade directly with the other
person who has something that they want
then maybe that they just aren't able to
make the trade like let's say tim's got
a bunch of benefits that's a good system
or are you just sort of saying that
descriptively um i don't think that just
because you have a lot of money means
that you're the guy that gets to pick
who gets to trade what let me tell you
guys the story i don't think that's i
don't think that's what currency does
let me tell you guys a story this is a
story about occupy wall street okay one
day i was at occupy wall street and i
saw a woman who had a table and on that
table she had a whole bunch of socialism
books
and i heard her talking to somebody
about how money is the root of all of
our problems when you get rid of money
and i was like i'm i'm with it i'm like
alright cool i hear you i hear you i'm
you know i'm confused right so i asked
her i was like so you don't think we
should have money and she goes no we
shouldn't people should get access to
equal goods i said okay here i have a
problem so here at occupy wall street i
go out on these marches and i live
stream them that's a real value to the
people who are protesting because then
people can hear and see and share right
it's like right yes of course and i was
like okay should i get something in
exchange for doing something of value
for the community and said well
absolutely and i said right
when i leave to go when people to follow
these marches and film them
when i by the time i come back
all of the food has been given away
because the people who aren't working
walk up get the food for nothing and
then by the time i'm back from doing
work there's no food left and she said
well then maybe we hold some of the food
for you
you know and and i said okay i like the
idea how do we track who you know i'm
i'm asking her in all sincerity i'm like
how do we track you know do we have like
a list of people it's like we have to
have these this food for these people
would it get complicated and she goes
well maybe they issue like vouchers
they'll give you like a piece of paper
that represents the work you did or
something and i went like money
hilarious and she was like no no no not
like money and i'm like but if i had a
voucher that just said it was worth some
kind of trade meat like it was worth the
work i did i could trade that with
someone else and they could turn it in
for the food it's called scrip
corporations used to do that well that's
a type of money it's a type of currency
called scrip and they would corporations
would give out script to their workers
and you can only use it at the company
yeah but if i don't want to buy from
that company store right that's the
problem and that's why we have currency
we have money that we can use as an as
you know so that i could if i don't want
tim's bananas but but he wants what i've
got bread and you've got gems to sell me
that to make jewelry or something you
know i i don't want all these things and
so we trade in money in order to get
those the downside is even the rich guy
can can get a big loan and have all this
funny money that he can buy all the
stuff
because he had access to the dollars so
so the money it's like money what is the
value of money galactic federation uses
credits
yeah but i don't think they really would
at that point if they're materializing
matter they wouldn't need that stuff you
got to watch star trek man because you
know what you're talking about platinum
i mean brown doesn't even know what he's
talking about do you even watch star
trek bro do you even space journey
are we going to have a conversation on
economics
gene roddenberry's work
i'm down to table this talk
i actually pulled up a few of the key
differences between money and currency i
was like this is a great question so
money can be stored uh sorry money can
be a store of value and is intangible in
nature currency cannot be a store of
value although it is always tangible in
nature so tangibility money refers to
actual value of goods or services that's
traded for currency is just a medium
that we keep in our pockets to increase
our purchasing power and to make
day-to-day payments in our lives that
that sounds like bs because that makes
sense
i don't see how that makes sense i don't
understand what money is yeah there's
cash then there's there's digital dot
dots ones and zeros in a bank ledger
somewhere those are different okay so
maybe that's what they're saying yeah so
money is what you have in your bank
account right currency is what i what i
have in my wallet right okay so that's a
dollar i don't know that's interesting
yeah cause they're also saying that
money has intrinsic value which you
could easily argue that fed money does
not happen
right so that makes sense actually
because all the money that it was
printed wasn't really printed by the fed
they just put it into their ledger right
but they're just adding money they're
not adding currency into the market oh
there's there i don't i don't believe
there will ever be a circumstance in
which we will not have money yeah i
don't know
we have to have money i don't think that
there's any way like you said because if
you are going out and videoing something
how can somebody trade that with you
there's uh
you know first we have the the laws of
thermodynamics right
so even when they're conceptualizing a
show like star trek the next generation
they try there's a real there's really
interesting contradictions in the
contradictions in the show where in some
instances they're like we've we don't
use money anymore because we have
replicators but they have beachfront
they have la they have riverfront
property or bay front property in san
francisco like how do you uh how do you
distribute wealth or or allocate
resources
so
i don't know how that would make sense
living in a star trek style future with
no money but someone gets to live on the
bay no there's value there and people
will strive and say how do i do
something to earn more is it appointed
to you well communists have tried
arguing star trek is communist and they
explain this is one of the reasons why
the problem is in the actual show they
couldn't overcome logical fallacies or
logical plot conundrums without
explaining the use of money why would
there be a need for exploration if you
could replicate everything ah the
replicators can't make certain complex
substances so you have to go and find
them and get them otherwise it would be
a show about a bunch of gods flying
around do whatever they wanted there'll
be no constraints so within the within
the laws of physics when we try
conceptualizing a science fiction show
we're like there's there has to be money
otherwise they're just teleporting gods
who can do whatever they want because
they're constrained by nothing well yeah
and also even if it were the case that
we ended up in some kind of
post-scarcity landscape the reality is
it's really an incoherent idea because
your time will always be scarce
there's always going to be an
opportunity cost to everything you do
post scarcity isn't even like i said
it's not a coherent concept in this
world i i believe your your time is the
most your most valuable resource way
more than any amount of money you could
be given on birth so like what you do
with your life is is the value
and also like what am i going to get for
what i give maybe that's a archaic
concept like why do you why do people
feel like they need something in return
for giving just if they have enough
survival if you have enough to survive
and to thrive then sustainability why
must we profit you know it's just for
your children yeah if you have enough to
sustain and your children have enough to
sustain them why do you need to rip
people off and rip people off or why do
you need to get things from
people
over here it's just a difference i get
what he's saying and i think that there
may be is a solution to it where it's
like there's a cap where you've had okay
so it doesn't hurt the farmers and it
doesn't hurt even the millionaires it's
like there's a cap and then the rest of
that has to be i disagree i i absolutely
disagree why is there a system of profit
um well some people are good at things
and some people aren't yeah but some
people are born into it right that is
true right some people are good things
in some people that's true but some
people are getting things not because
they're good at something right but
that's that's that's that's like an
issue but if so if you have a system
where some dude is like i've figured out
a way to create energy that's extremely
effective you know and efficient
and then we say but we're going to put a
limit on how much you can actually grow
your business that's a bad thing well no
no john rockefeller did that exact thing
he figured out how to transport oil with
pipelines and then they had to break up
his company because it was too powerful
uh standard oil
so i'm saying like
stopping monopolies is different from
telling the little guy he can't have 30
or more employees you know actually
sounds the same
i don't think so yeah i mean it's
exactly the same thing if you're going
to break up a monopoly you are saying to
that business owner you cannot have x y
thing no matter how good you are at
getting that thing but i'm talking about
scale i'm not talking about like
principle yeah hard law i'm saying that
like censorship for instance censorship
is actually a good thing depending on
the context if someone's posting child
abuse on websites we certainly want
censors to like get rid of that find
those people and arrest them we don't
want our political opinions to be
censored that's you know but then
there's a challenge in what constitutes
a political opinion so you have morality
issues if there's one company that
controls all communications and they're
censoring their political rivals or it's
a cabal in silicon valley we got a very
serious problem if it's like one small
website who is having their domain
seized by big
companies so we want to protect the
smaller you know a guy so
my point is
yes in certain circumstances anti-trust
makes sense but the idea someone is
allowed to earn more money they're not
ripping somebody off they're allowed to
expand their business we just don't want
them to control all of the market
you know what i mean
that's true
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and we'll see you all there